hey guys i'm really excited to show this
video to you because uh i got a chance
to play mario kart with the man who
created mario i just i just want to let
that sink in for a second
because i'm still trying to wrap my mind
around it and just so you know the tv
that we were all playing on was really
far away so it was hard for all three of
us to see it but that is the excuse that
i'm going to stick with because
i didn't play my best so i'm not so
proud i was a little bit nervous i mean
really trying to prove your skills in
front of somebody who made
mario
anyway enjoy so do you guys have a
specific mario kart player that's your
favorite
i'll
be know what i'm gonna be mario so
they're collins
and i'll be linked okay perfect okay
oh we have to challenge i gotta make
sure my acceleration is
oh yeah let's see it's all about the
acceleration
and do you guys prefer bikes or carts
oh either one's fine but i've decided on
a cart here we go and let's see he likes
the gamecube yoshi circuit okay
so you know why is this your favorite
well
it's simple
i remember when the mario kart for
gamecube came out and i got in trouble
in college because i didn't go to class
for a week and the instructors called my
mom and was like she's not showing up to
class is she okay
all right here we go here we go
oh man i'm already i'm already in
this bike is hard to control
we maybe should have picked
oh you want double pizza please
i'm in first place right now i'm in
fourth here we go oh gosh i just said i
just had a wall we need to take this tv
off the wall
move it a little closer
so i think you guys probably have a
little bit of an advantage to playing
this oh why is that oh i don't know
i'm doing ah with the wii wheel i'm
third right now i'm pretty impressed
actually but that's that's pretty
impressive
are you power sliding i am okay that's
even more impressive
but how is it creating this game to live
up to so many different years
and so many generations of people who
enjoy it
well our goal really is just to try to
do something new every time so as long
as we keep doing that it's not too bad
speaking of not too bad
our goal is always just to make
something that we find fun and usually
if we're able to do that then
we think other people will find it fun
too well it's a lot of fun and it's
amazing because anybody that picks it up
it's just a fun game across so many
generations except when you lose and i'm
in eighth place i'm really embarrassed
i was hoping i would do a little better
i haven't even finished the map yet
he got fourth place
i got second okay okay well
i'm really embarrassed
it's funny because when i was younger i
used to think that i was the best mario
kart player because i could beat all of
my friends until the internet came
around and i realized my friends just
weren't very good and so imam
foreign
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know what your favorite mario kart
character is to play with do you prefer
a bike do you prefer the carts and what
is your favorite map of all time i'm
creating the original to now have an
amazing port of it in mario kart so
there